hello my name is marcus fonteora and i
work in azure core
welcome to the cloud intelligence aka
aiops track of the microsoft research
summit cloud computing has been
expanding rapidly
by waves of enterprises moving their i.t
operations to large cloud providers such
as microsoft azure but the market is
very competitive putting pressure on
cloud systems to deliver attractive
features
improve performance and security and
guarantee availability and reliability
while controlling costs and carbon
footprints these goals
call for a high integration of ai
technology into cloud computing cloud
computing platforms are distributed by
nature and they have a massive scale and
high complexity
these characteristics pose great
challenges as well as great
opportunities to the cloud intelligence
research which attracts researchers and
practitioners from multiple research
communities including ai systems and
software engineering
the development of machine learning
algorithms is just a piece of the puzzle
to make real world impact ai
technologies need to be landed in
production and continuously evolved
which calls
for the close collaboration between
academia and industry
in today's sessions we are very glad to
have a diverse set of speakers from
microsoft research
academia and industry talking about
their research and practice on different
aspects of cloud intelligence including
reliability performance efficiency
scalability and supply chain
we will conclude the day with a panel
discussion on how to accelerate cloud
intelligence across academia and the
industry
public cloud providers invest billions
of dollars into their software in other
infrastructures maximizing the use of
these expensive resources while
maintaining excellent performance and
availability is critical for
profitability and competitiveness
infusing intelligence into cloud
platforms has potential to achieve these
goals
taking at some of these advantages and
opportunities will have been
transforming the future of microsoft
azure
thank you for joining us
we are very excited about the research
in this field and we know you'll be as
well